[Music]
a very big hello and warm welcome and
joining us for the president's design
awards second webinar in the education
and careers series what they don't tell
you about a product and industrial
design career
my name is julian yao and i will be your
mc for today
the president's design award or pda for
short is singapore's highest accolade
for designers and designs across all
disciplines
organized by the design singapore
council and the urban redevelopment
authority this is the 13th cycle of the
award
the latest crop of 11 pda 2020
recipients were awarded on 30th of june
2021 and you can find the traveling
exhibition at the singapore university
of technology and design campus level 2
and it will be there until the 31st of
march 2022.
the next call for entries for pda 2023
will also be launching in september so
do follow design singapore council on
instagram for exciting updates
and just a couple of house rules just to
keep today's session running as smoothly
as possible firstly please be informed
that this webinar will be recorded and
that your microphones will be muted
throughout the session
you are however most welcome to submit
questions through the zoom q a function
and the speakers will address them
during the q a segment
should you encounter any technical
issues please do ping our technical team
via the zoom chat function
so in the second edition of the pda
education and career series students
fresh graduates and professionals
interested in a career in product
industrial and user experience design
will have an up close and personal
opportunity to dialogue with the
recipients of singapore's highest design
accolade
so how is the role of a product or
industrial designer like in reality and
how has it evolved over the years what
is on an employer's wish list when
looking out for prospective hires and
how can design graduates better prepare
for it what is the career progression in
this field like
so many questions that our panel of
speakers will be tackling today
and of course now it is my pleasure to
introduce the recipients on our panel
we have mr nathan yong founder of neijin
young design and pda 2008 designer of
the year
ms karen auer design director and
partner of chemistry and pda 2016 design
of the year for v-scan xs
mr jeremy sun
design director of orca design
consultants and pda 2013 designer of the
year for the initial signature range
mr casey young senior principal user
experience consultant of dell and pda
2013 design of the year for the dell
inspirion
2340 all-in-one pc
and our moderator for today is miss
victoria coo who is a lead ux researcher
at dbs bank and 2015 recipient of the
design singapore council scholarship
but now before we begin the session we
would like to get to know a little bit
more about you so tell us who you are
via the poll that will be launching on
your screen we're expecting a whole
series of different demographics today
so let us know whether you are a student
or perhaps you are a fresh graduate who
has just started working for one or two
years in the field or maybe you are
already a working professional in the
design or perhaps not in the design
industry just let us know in the poll
below we would certainly love to find
out more about you
so you should be seeing a poll that has
popped up on the screen if you can just
let us know over there we are expecting
a whole lot of different demographics
today and i'm pretty sure everything
that will be shared during the session
later
we would all greatly benefit whether or
not you're still in school whether
you're in the field
you've just started in the field
all the questions above would be super
interesting for you to know okay we're
seeing a very good mix actually 40 of
you are students
and we've got 14 who are fresh graduates
those who have been working in the field
for one or two years and a 47 of you are
working professionals
okay now that we know that can you tell
us a little bit more about your
background and which fields that you are
currently studying or working in you can
definitely choose more than one option
but our options are number one product
and industrial design would it be to ui
ux design would it be three visual
communications or perhaps your
advertising
number four would be architecture and or
interior design number five perhaps you
are in another design discipline or
number six maybe you're not in design
maybe thinking about it but you're here
to find out more it's gonna be very
interesting if we start seeing a lot of
people in number six i would imagine i'm
gonna predict that maybe we're gonna see
a little bit more uh people on the
product and industrial design side today
considering the topic for today
but again i wouldn't be
too surprised if there are people from
non-design disciplines who are here to
find out a little bit more perhaps
thinking about a career switch perhaps
you've been doing it on the side and you
just want to hear from the experts so
share with us especially if you're from
other design disciplines if you're going
to be choosing number five or perhaps
you are in a non-design discipline type
in the chat below let us know which
industry you're currently in it will be
very very interesting for us to find out
where our audience is from today we are
also going to be taking a look at the
poll results to see
um where some of you are from and yes i
think we've kind of predicted there are
the right answers 41 percent of you are
from the product and industrial design
industry we have 13 of you in the ui ux
design surprisingly no nobody in
advertising or visual communications
here perhaps you're a bit too shy to
press that button 11 of you in
architecture and interior design 10 in
other design disciplines and a pretty
staggering 25 of you come from
non-design discipline so
whether or not you're currently already
in the design line
i'm pretty sure you're going to be
drawing some inspiration and information
from our panel today so that was just a
simple one to get things started thank
you so much for your participation in
the polls now that we've gotten to know
each other a little bit better let's go
straight into the sharing by our
speakers
and without further ado let us welcome
our first speaker mr nathan young
after graduating from thomasic
polytechnic with a diploma in industrial
design in 1991 nathan began his career
as a buyer who traveled extensively to
source for quality manufacturers and
craftsmen to develop furniture and home
accessories nathan won the prestigious
red dot concept design award for two
consecutive years in 2006 and 2007 and
in 2008 he received the distinguished
president's design award designer of the
year
nathan's work has been exhibited
globally in design centers in singapore
shizuoka milan london cone and taipei
and has appeared in international
magazines like wallpaper monocle surface
dwell on office and habitus
his work is inspired by observation of
the visual environment and then
challenges the existential questions of
the objects instead of superfluous
details he captures the poultry of
products through a stripping process
lending the object quantities that are
informed by a lightness of restraints so
nathan over to you please
thank you juliana
hi everyone thanks for coming in after
lunch break
um
so um i'm living young i've been doing
product design for last 20 years
starting from my own business when i
graduated around 23 years old i actually
didn't work as product designer i was
like what juliana said i was a buyer i
was a salesman
doing everything except design
until i opened my own shop at 29 years
old
so i just want to go through some of the
slides that i've been
oh sorry
it's a bit slow okay
i think it's very important to be
authentic that's what i'm going to show
you my parents uh to let you guys know
about my background
i'm really old i'm at 51 years old right
now so you see the pictures of the old
singapore that's the environment i grew
up with it's beside a shipyard
and that's my parents
my parents and my sisters so i say in a
place where it's beside shibuya where i
can see all the nitty-gritty
construction
and hardship around actually uh in
singapore
let me just click a bit sorry
so i find beauty in understanding how
things work naturally and not in shape
and form
for example these three objects that i
picked up from a garage i just
find them beautiful just clean up and
spray them in white color just to go
back to their
their basic form and i find them
beautiful
again things like i go to the
industry of furniture furniture design
because i think furniture design has a
lot more freedom of expression
than let's say uh electronic products
and um these are some of the objects
that i've designed before uh
like
side table that's informed by rubbish
bin
uh coffee table
inspired by flying papers
that you can see from any uh clinics
your friend's place all their books and
papers are thrown around it has never
been a nice tidy coffee table
so i just thought what's the point of
designing a nice table so instead it's
just
flying papers all around
the feeling of sitting inside
a shelter in a bomb shelter something
like that for a sofa
let me just show you back how the sofa
looks like
it's like a cocooning yourself inside a
very safe
um
comfort of cushions and all that
you probably get the drift i don't
explain it you probably get where i get
my inspiration from so
it should be as simple as that
and this this is the first uh coffee
table that got me
chosen to
get my product in leaner roses a french
company
and that's where i start to design for
overseas client
some local projects like h m
in which i'm tasked to design a bench
for a laneway festival a rock concert
uh at marina bay sand they wanted
benches for
vip to sit on
so i got a feeling that when you listen
to rock music you start to flow and
enjoy the whole thing so i get my ideas
from a ship hall
and that's the meter is where the design
is at and you can see some of the
the audience sitting on the bench
and the way it's constructed in malaysia
to raid.award
close hangar and computer
and then design coffin also during the
last tsunami
uh it's stackable so that we don't ship
air out from the
the the airplane would take a lot of
space so i designed it to be stackable
and kind of a stem printing on chipboard
so this one won the second red dot award
i also collaborate with disney for star
wars so
i got a form for four spacecraft from
star wars and created objects for the
home
these are mostly side table saw stools
yeah
and i'm using a solid marble
these are jewel project the benches
blah blah
exam overseas client that um
i sell to
design will enrich in north america they
got
i think 40 of the shops they own my
herman miller
and they have all the classics in the
shop
and this is the piece that got me uh um
into the shop in the first place it was
a tv console
and then we developed further into
cabinet sites cabinet they made
everything from this collection so it's
good for me
it paid the bills
and this is and this is some of the
designers that's been with them most of
them are dead
except me still alive
very happy
and the french
yeah so this is what i've designed for
them
a lot of these are very periodic because
as i said
i like to do furniture design because it
gives me more freedom of expression
i also run a furniture shop called
grafang i founded this in
so it's about 12 years now
we're at funan center which we bring in
all the brands i mean all the brands we
bring brands from europe from japan
yeah and this is the brands that i have
in and also including my brand folks up
there
where it's made in malaysia and export
to europe and usa
i think that's about all
thank you very much nathan
and our next speaker is karen our design
director and partner of chemistry
karen has the experience in service
design projects at chemistry where she
works with the team to crop engaging
user experiences across various
industries
originally from austria karen has worked
across the globe for companies like
kessel's creamer and ideo prior to
joining chemistry
she holds master's degrees in
communication and experience design so
karen strongly believes in the
transformative power of human centered
design whether applied to public service
streams or whole city districts this
concern for strong impact with a clear
social component can also be seen in
passion projects such as the four impact
organization education international
which focuses on giving access to
education for bright students in
developing countries so karen over to
you
thanks a lot and hello everyone
i'm actually enjoying this sharing as
well just seeing what nathan has shared
shows like how broad and diverse the
design practice can be so let me share a
little bit about my own design practice
so my name is karen
and i am um as chair um design director
and partner at chemistry chemistry is a
strategic design consultancy based both
in singapore and amsterdam and we are
very much impact driven
so the kind of work that we do
puts both people and the planet at the
center of our work
so the way that we approach design is
really from a planet-centric point of
view
but what i want to share with you today
is a little bit more of how i got into
design and how i actually ended up where
i am now um it was already a little bit
um hinted at in this introduction and
actually i came from
um quite a varied background and i have
been living and working in a variety of
different countries and that has really
shaped my view and design and shaped my
practice
um and wherever i am now i'm pretty sure
that's not going to be um the final
destination there's more to come
so my journey into design and out of it
uh it all started off in vienna so
that's where i'm originally from when i
did my first masters there in visual
communication design but i immediately
knew that i actually wanted more than
just that so i
spent some more time in the netherlands
where the chance invited them to also
experience such design
focusing on illustration and typography
then i moved to berlin where i actually
worked a little bit in advertising um i
heard no one from advertising background
is joining us today i personally also
did not very much enjoy working in this
field um so i moved on to london where
did a second master focus on an
experience design
and so you can already see here how my
view on design what a designer can do
and which part of the process you're
involved is something that i
continuously tried to push and also just
started to explore as i was i'm going
from education into actual um practice
from london i then moved to surrey where
i was working in an urban think tank
looking at the future visions for cities
and finally then made my move to japan
um to asia which was at that time for me
a quite scary big move having never been
in asia before but really unfulfilling
and since now 10 years i haven't left
asia from tokyo working at the
university and then finally um in 2011
moved to singapore
as i was moving across all those
different countries i was also moving
through disciplines and i was moving
through different kinds of fields that i
was looking at and different kinds of
challenges i was working on
so
what i learned in university is still
relevant to some extent but i can
definitely say that my practice and my
viewing design has expanded far beyond
it and i can definitely guarantee that
it will further expand and i think i can
guarantee everyone here on this call
that your definition of design will
continue to expand as well
so what i want to
go through today is a
quick overview of i think four projects
that i've done in the recent years that
can be mapped on something called the
design spheres this is actually a
framework developed by richard buchanan
very interesting concept that maps out
the different um challenge arenas or
different challenge spaces that
designers work in and how those
challenge spaces are continuously
growing and expanding this is by no
means a ranking that one is less than
the other it's just highlighting how
actually we as designer continuously
look at different and um and more
complex problems which is
scary but also very exciting
so the first project that i want to um
talk about is um
like in the space of visual
communication design actual phone bill
so this was a project we did um several
years ago uh with synctel those of you
who actually are single customers and
still get uh
a printed bill micro familiar with that
so this was all about making a phone
bill i wouldn't say
uh delightful but at least less painful
so really redesigning completely the
consumer and enterprise bill
understanding how can we make it easy to
understand clear to view and uh reduce
the bill shock that some of us might get
when we actually view this bill so as
mentioned before was really about
starting with the users understanding
their need
but moving beyond designing symbols
visual communication the next
sphere of design is things designing
products and objects like for example an
ultrasound device
this was a project that we um did
together with mge healthcare and it
actually won the president's design of
order 2016. um focusing on how we could
empower midwives with technology
specifically
an ultrasound device and the interesting
part of this project was that we were
focusing very um clearly on a focus on a
user group in sub-saharan africa and in
rural indonesia or myanmar so places
have very specific needs whether medical
practitioners are highly skilled but we
have to work in a really rough
environment so really understanding how
we can create a device for
the physical object as well as the
interface that is intuitive
and easy to use for them so we spend a
lot of time in their environment
understanding their needs understanding
the work environment and really
understanding how we can create a design
a device that really works for them and
what is exciting for me is that this is
not only rolled out successfully in
indonesia and in various african
countries
we actually also see it being picked up
increasingly in europe where the
mobility the sturdiness and the very
intuitive interface designed for people
who really need to be able to work very
quickly and pick it up um easily
resonates just as much
so this is really looking at how design
focused on people putting the use at the
center can create really impactful
solutions
but moving on in our framework from
symbols
to objects further out to interactions
and this is really one of the key areas
that i am working on are in recent years
actually designing experiences exciting
um services where you bring together
various aspects of design various
domains of design and one of the
projects i want to share here is
a yearly engagement that we did for the
woodlands hospital this is um still
under construction unfortunately delayed
due to covet but nonetheless very
exciting because it was actually giving
us the chance to rethink what a hospital
with a human touch could be like where
we can combine technology to make it
efficient with more seamless and um
user-centric or patient-centric
processes to make it again i wouldn't
say delightful but a lot less stressful
that hospitals often can be so we looked
at designing the pharmacy the outpatient
clinic in even the patient service
center
um conducting a lot of research to
understand what works what doesn't work
but also doing extensive prototyping so
we actually build out the full pharmacy
space for example as you can see it here
and tested not only the physical layout
how the counters would look like as well
as the digital touch points for example
the um the kiosk for registration as
well as the app that would um guide um
patients through the campus but we also
looked at the processes and we tested
that out together with staff with people
in the community as well as with the
hospital with finance
and all that allowed us to then put
forward a very comprehensive experience
blueprint looking as uh at the layout
spatial arm design as well as the
digital design
but for the last approach a final
project that i want to share with you
today i want to move even further out in
my um diagram and i think that is really
the most exciting part for me the news
um development where i see design going
designing actual systems because the
more complex the world is in which we
are working as designers the more we
need to be really aware of not only the
product itself and how it impacts the
users but also how it impacts the system
that the product will be used and this
includes of course the organization the
business but even the whole ecosystem so
one example that um we're currently
working on is a project with the fashion
ecosystem and this idea of a
systems-based approach for design is
also something that is fundamental to
the idea of a more sustainable approach
to design
so what we are focusing on um more and
more is to really look at how can we
move from a linear economy from a linear
approach to design to more circular
economy and a circular approach to
design so not a single um use
a life cycle for product where we
extract resources create a product use
it and then dispose of it but we
actually try to reuse things recycle
things and close the loop and keep the
value of the product
within the system so specifically here
we're working together with taf the
taxon fashion association in singapore
as well as the austrian fashion
association with a european union grant
and a partner of us in amsterdam on
looking at how we can create more
lasting relationships with clothing so
tracking the ownership and the
provenance of fast fashion goods on a
blockchain thinking through the whole
system what it would mean if you would
keep clothing longer or if you could
track the history of our clothing how
this could not only change our behavior
with our clothing but also how this
could change the overall value chain of
fashion
this is really something that is very
exciting and close to my heart to really
see how we as designer can move forward
so then lastly i think the key is to
know that your education is not a
blueprint for your career you will
continuously have to expand and push it
what you have now is a way of thinking
and it's going to get a lot more
exciting as you move forward
all right thank you so much karen for
your insightful sharing next up we have
jeremy sun design director of oracle
design consultants
orca design consultants is a strategic
design and research consultancy with
studios in singapore and malaysia
under jeremy's stewardship orca design
has been empowering clan's business
through innovative strategies and
solutions
jeremy has been on both ends of design
awards both as a jury as an
award-winning team lead with
international accolades
he has been leading design thinking and
ethnographic research and innovation
programs for both fortune 500 companies
government agencies international brands
local corporates sme and educational
institutions guiding the stakeholders to
reframe challenges creating compelling
visions and propositions and crafting
innovations that resonate with their
target audiences so jeremy over to you
jeremy if i think you're you might be
muted
yeah thank you juliana
thank you to uh to see you all here uh
it has been a interesting opportunity
for me to share some of my personal
thoughts which usually wouldn't share
in the typical you know events and i'm
very inspired you know by looking at the
uh the sharing
from both nathan as well as karen
so this topic really
makes makes a point because i realized
you know after working for almost 30
years
there are a lot of things that are
we're not told when we're students or
even at the beginning of our career so i
would be you know very happy to share
some of these some might apply to you
but some may not but i hope that you
know you'll find some of the points
useful
just a quick glance of the the project
we've been doing
in the past few years
as you can see that you know it's not
just about product design and the
typical definition of industrial design
as uh karen puts very well beyond
products and objects they're also
digital solutions service experience
design etc etc
also including innovation workshop
facilitation as well as coaching
so back to the question how i started i
would say um it was a
bit of an interest plus a bit of a luck
because as a high school student i
clearly didn't know what design was
about
what caught my attention was a list of
subjects to be studied for industrial
design which sounds quite interesting
and different from the usual ones
well it did help that you know building
lego objects was my favorite childhood
hobby
and that arts and crafts seems to be
quite enjoyable for me
so one of the things i learned quite
early in my career is that graduation
from a design course master start of a
lifelong learning journey it doesn't end
the learning in fact it it actually
opens up you know the whole new journey
of learning
so
in fact over the years i have been
working on project that i didn't expect
i will when i just graduated
as karen's put it the key design skills
remain important but the scope of work
has evolved so much that my professors
wouldn't have known what was coming our
way and couldn't have warned us in
advance and prepare us enough
i think and so in fact this is an
understatement to say that you know it's
the beginning of lifelong learning the
reality is that
learn or obsolete
it sounds a bit harsh but that's exactly
you know how the the world of design
goes
and also like it or not being a designer
is never just about design so over the
years i've come across you know some
people saying that i'm here to design
i'm employed to design so i'm not here
to do this or that
so um i hope i'm not being you know
discouraging but design is not a
standalone or isolated activity that are
served by you know a a team
more than that
more often than that designers need to
be self-serving which means looking for
the missing puzzles or make things
happen if it's not happening yet
so in fact a lot of non-design-centric
types are in a part of our
responsibilities and learning and
executing these tasks makes us a better
designer
i've also learned that you're not you
are the only one in the team who speaks
design
so therefore it's important to make your
design and yourself understood
particularly in the team made of
multi-disciplinary members
designers are usually the only persons
who know what design is about and speaks
design
so it's our responsibility to make
ourselves and our work understood for
example finding ways to better
communicate the thoughts and outcomes
instead of expecting others to read our
mind
and we know how important is creativity
we can't overemphasize that and
creativity is essential but it is not
enough by by itself
and what i meant is that
a lot of the soccer results of the
project come from the uh
the execution with meticulous minds as
well as you know um
effort
so i've also we have also heard of
people saying that in ideas are cheap
which is in a way it's true because it's
the execution that can bring ideas to
life and deliver the intended impacts
but to be fair i like to say that good
ideas are not exactly cheap
there are also
different sorts of roles designers can
play and should play so let's not start
in the idea that you know designers do
design making design and that's the only
roles they can play in fact really based
on your interests
as well as your experiences and skills
there are many roles we can play
being designers
so here i just have a quick list of you
know the different types of design roles
we can play so we can ask ourselves what
are the roles that we're currently
playing
are we uh
also playing the world of applicator
are we planning the whole projects are
we also doing research
are we facilitating the whole team to
create results
or do we actually work more on the
engineering side invention site or even
educating
but the question is also
what are the roles you wish to play next
which might be different from
what you're doing currently and what
needs to be done in order for you to
reach that
this brings me to think about um right
brain and levering because i also teach
you know creative thinking and design
and this is a a very
interesting aspect
because we tend to think of design
skills as the most important things and
it is indeed important but i also like
to look at in another aspect which is
called talents
so everyone is born with certain type of
talents
and these are the traits and
inclinations that often come from within
it's not just
a born capabilities but they can also be
cultivated
so in the context of design designer i
look at the talents that can be roughly
categorized into library and right brain
right brain represents
in the blue color represent the blue sky
because it's it's about inner
imagination
and a creation
whereas the lip brain is represented
with green sort of the color of the
ground the land which will ground us
so depending on your interest as well as
your talents you might find in a certain
area that you're most interested in and
certain type of roles you would like to
play
and i also realized that in the design
industry somehow people focus a little
bit more on the the blue side which is
the right brain function but over the
years i realized how important it is to
have the other side to balance the the
work and the output it's important to
have someone who is very structural very
organizational analytical in order to
deliver that necessary vision as well as
the communication
so one of the examples we can see here
is that
if you
you know try to map
yourself
on this you can clearly see what is your
diagram so the question is
do we need to further strength in
certain parts or do we need to in the
leverage on the our stronger talents
so knowing and cultivating our design
talents beyond honing our design skills
is very important because that sort of
you know designs but
define what sort of designers we are
and this also brings me to uh think
about
a very
useful way of thinking
especially in recent years
when people talk about ikigai
ikikai means the purpose in life so in
fact for us
as designers we're probably also
thinking about this question and i
realized that if you're really into
design you probably find that design is
a vocation as well as a profession which
comes with a mission
quite often and that requires a passion
in order for us to go far
that brings brings me to talk about one
of the projects
we we've done a few years ago which kind
of reflects such aspects of a design
career
it is not about creating the most
desirable products with the fanciest
features
but instead is to understand the needs
and aspirations of the people in this
case the seniors to share the learning
as well as to guide the designers and
innovators to create meaningful
solutions
a project that focuses on how to
[Music]
create a
meaningful and relatable technological
solution for the aging society
the project was um quite a turning point
in my career because i started to see
you know how design could uh benefit a
benefit the society and not just in a
benefiting
let's say a manufacturer
this project led to a series of
insight-driven projects related to aging
mental health and patient experience etc
so with the last slide
would be my um no not yet
uh
my attempt to define what is designed in
key guy
if it actually exists
so because there are problems and needs
that exists that need to be you know
addressed and improved or fulfilled as
well as changes in our world
that um call for solutions
designers are required
in this context to help understand and
address the needs of the changes
but each one of us are different
so how do we find our iki gai
so
in my mind there are three ways we can
look at it first is look at our
aspiration what drives us
second is as we briefly mentioned what
are our talents what are in our in us
and third one which is very important is
about grids it's about our we what we
are willing to go through and put
through in order to reach our goals
so if you put you know these three
together you can see that uh when
aspiration matches the talents we have a
direction
when we had the grids and the talents we
had the expertise something we're very
good at
but there might be a gap between you
know aspiration and where we want to go
and but with the grids there will be
growth
so if we put these three together we can
roughly say that uh we probably have
found our purpose in design career
and as you can see you know we can um
this uh it's been you know uh testified
by many uh designers including
um nathan karen as well as casey
that will be you know a sharing
after me
so with that it ends uh my sharing and i
hope that you know you can find
something useful in your future
development
thank you
thank you very much jeremy and last but
not least let us welcome casey young
senior principal user experience
consultant of dell
casey young is the user experience
leader in dell singapore specializing in
ergonomics usability behavior research
interaction design and user interface
design his expertise is in uncovering
users tested needs and aligning them
with business strategies prior to dell
he was in creative technology and dso
national laboratories his passion for
design has translated to numerous
prestigious awards including the
singapore president's design award
international design excellence award
and the red dot design award
casey is also the president-elect of the
human factors and ergonomic society of
singapore and his aspiration is to build
a strong team in extending the reach and
relevance of human factors and
ergonomics to achieve the ultimate goal
in driving human progress so casey over
to you
thank you gianna
hi everyone my name is casey
to start off i would like to just to
give everyone a walkthrough of my design
experience
my first experience started when i was
doing my first degree in university of
birmingham
when i learned about ergonomics
i was intrigued about how
products are designed
based on human needs and capability
with that strong interest i continued to
pursue this domain
when i was doing my master's in ngu
and i learned about human computer
interactions
when i graduated i joined the military
organizations dso
where i become a human factor specialist
and in dso i have the opportunity to
design sophisticated combine and control
rooms and console
then i decided to join the private
sector creative wanting to learn about a
software user interface
then in 2007 i joined dell
this is my 15 years with dell
i am very fortunate to be able to work
with an incredible team that makes 15
years flies
before i share with you about the user
experience design and dell product i
would like to share some interesting
facts about dell singapore
firstly
all dell display and peripherals are
designed and developed in singapore and
that includes the mouse keyboard
conference speakers webcam
headsets and many more
secondly
for display in terms of the worldwide
market share we are number one for eight
consecutive years and we are very
honored that people have chosen this as
their choice and we will continue to
innovate and deliver the best to our
customers
now over the years we have service
learning and i would like to share with
you our experience
now
the first design philosophy
that we have is to get to know your
users and observe their behavior
understand their
habits their workflow the environment
and focus in helping them to increase
their productivity
now in the commercial world we have
learned that many users use multiple
windows when they are working
imagine every game they start working
and they need to make adjustments to the
windows in long term that's actually a
significant loss in terms of
productivity
now to boost productivity
we offer the users a way to manage the
windows
now users can choose a layout based on
their workflow and easily snap the
window onto it such functionalities let
you not only conveniently tile your
favorite applications also increase your
workflow
quickly snap your applications into one
of
now for the
needs and workflow
now we learned that this group of
professionals that they actually
calibrate their monitor regularly
and to ensure power accuracies
now conventionally
users have to set up a color calibration
device they have to wait at least 30
minutes for the monitor to warm up
and then wait for another 20 to 60
minutes to calibrate the monitor before
they start work
so to cut down the hassle we integrate
the color calibration device and enable
users to share do their calibrations and
this allows them to warm up the display
and calibrate before they arrive in the
studio
that results is actually a big saving of
time for the users
this is the alienware display and in
designing this alienware display we
collaborated with the professionals
esports team team liquid we gathered
valuable feedback from them and
incorporate their feedback into the
product
we also went to the esports competition
to observe how the game and we noticed
that the gamers place the keyboard at an
angle while they are playing
we learned that the reason why they are
doing so is that to place the hand and
rings at a very natural comfortable
position
now the issue is that many of the
monitors have very bulky stance and
interfere with the display
so gamers are unable to place the game
the keyboards uh the way that you want
now with this insights we specifically
design
the legs in a table manual a very keen
manual and to make it steel enough for
the keyboard to slide in without
interference and this enables the gamers
to place their keyboard at a very
perfect angle that they want
his second design philosophy is to pay
attention to every details of the design
understand how they put impact on
ergonomics
there are many other there are many
considerations that are
not obvious but important to our users
and customers the considerations comes
from listening to the users the
customers those who are purchasing the
it devices and observing their workspace
let me share with you some insights here
now we hear from our customers that
office rental has gone up significantly
companies are optimizing the space so
that they can accommodate more staff
this consideration has in turn
influenced customers decisions in
purchasing spinach's and i.t d systems
we saw that this is a consequence of
this trend would be a smaller table
and this compromises the user's viewing
distance
now in this diagram and on the right uh
it basically shows the conventional
display and that gives the users a
shorter viewing distance that is not
ideal and the reason is because the
display has the largest stance design
and the typical panel
now the newer ultra 10 display on the
left
has a small set stand design and a
thinner panel and that gives users a
long viewing distance
now apart from the optimal viewing
distance
the new monitors also have smaller
footprint and tasks free of space for
the users and this is a good example
uh how we go beyond basic and
guidelines to meet the needs of the
users and customers
the third design philosophy is
anticipate
gaps in new norms help users to deal
with them
now during kovic many people are working
from home and we hear people complains
about clutters
on their small desks
the laptops the keyboard the mouse
microphone camera speakers
are all fighting for spaces
and the workspace look very cluttered
and spacey and that's why
we design a display that integrate all
the peripherals together only one single
product so users don't have to deal with
the setups and the messy cables
the webcam also has adjustable tubes
capture
users in the best position
the speakers are strategically placed at
the top of the screens that align the
users to the year allowing them to hear
clearly
and thanks to the ai technology
the cameras automatically frame the user
so no matter where the users are their
face is always in the middle of the
screen
the last philosophy is in dale we strive
for more inclusive design
so that our products can be used by as
many people as possible including some
with special needs
and when we are designing the large
interactive display we notice that some
users are unable to reach the content at
the top of the screen users
has such challenge includes those who
are on the wheel and those shorter users
such as children
to overcome the issues we come up with a
way
to allow users
to bring the screen down
and then give them options to choose the
height that they would like to
and this is a great example of new
design for all
this is a quick recap of the fall design
philosophy they serve as a reminder for
me
to think about users changing needs and
inspiring
i hope they can inspire you too
thank you
thank you very much casey and thank you
recipients for sharing on your inspiring
and impactful projects i'll now hand the
time over to our moderator victoria for
the q and a session
so victoria is a service designer with a
specialty in user experience research
she is a lead ux researcher at dbs
bank's group design where she champions
user centricity and coaches business and
product teams to embed customer insights
to drive innovation
trained also as a product designer in
her undergraduate years victoria has
been driven by the passion to bring
delightful experiences to people's
everyday interactions with products and
services
besides banking and finance i
experienced fans working on projects in
diverse industries such as retail fmb
technology transport and education so
welcome victoria and the recipients
yeah thank you so much juliana and i was
such an inspiring um sharing from the
speakers and well thank you listeners uh
for your enthusiasm i already see quite
a few uh questions streaming in so do
keep your questions coming in but
without further ado let's get cracking
with the questions um yeah as uh juliana
shed i was previously a product designer
trained again in my master's in service
design but things has changed um since i
graduated you know so i would like to
ask uh the speakers
how has the product and industrial
design industry changed um since you
started um i know several of you come
from different disciplines but and how
do you think you know this will
transform in the future
maybe i'll start with this
right
in the past um
we have been designing
kind of like products they are kind of
standalone like for example monitor
and then
then we move on to design like keyboard
and things like that and as things has
become smarter and smarter
and users are expecting the products to
look simpler
now that is the challenge where you know
designers have to deal with the
complexity
how to actually present the product how
to design product
that looks
simple
pleasing
and yet it's smart and connected and it
works together with different
peripherals all together
and that is something that the
experience that we have got and
and the challenge that we are kind of
facing
and to deliver something that the users
want
you know being simple and easy to use
thank you so much casey
um actually i was interested to to hear
from jeremy because
uh you've mentioned that you know when
you got into industrial design or
product design um there are some things
your professor didn't tell you right and
and could you share uh along this line
of of of thinking what you expect or
imagine a role as a product design um
industrial designer would be versus the
reality today
and the ex with the experience that you
have now
yeah sure
um when i first graduated i believe that
all i thought in a designer is the the
one with design
right
um with a very narrow definition
but over the years i realized the design
the word itself as a verb covers so many
things i mean it starts from you know
the planning the strategy
um and
you are also you know at the same time
acting like an anthropologist
trying to understand um not just the
user but also the stakeholders all kinds
of stakeholders i mean the client's a
procurement team for example the
technician
um the cleaner et cetera and senator
anyone who might have in a brief or
long-term relationship with the product
that we're designing we're there to
understand them and i realize
there's no one else who can take up this
role it is our responsibilities and it's
our responsibility to translate the
findings into solutions that can benefit
you know everyone
uh every stakeholder of that particular
solution so this is the kind of
revelation i would say over the years
that we realize
um our role is not really a silo job
man quite often we are the connector
we are also the implementer
yeah
so i hope it doesn't sound very uh
daunting or challenging
thank you jeremy yeah i think this
really resonates with what casey earlier
shared um where it's really about the
user you have many stakeholders and
expectations are changing um you're
dealing with a lot of complexity in
problems
um but i was wondering if nathan or
karen you have any response with you
know when you first started in this
industry um be it product or
industrial design i know karen you come
from a uh a visual comms um how do you
think it has transformed in in your past
experience
maybe i'll just start with
i think there's not much change for
financial design or home accessories
because it's basically a low-tech
industry
i mean there are some technology like
six axis uh cnc machine and all that but
all those play a very small part in the
whole outcome of furniture um
from design to production to what people
needs are
and i think that's the reason why i go
to furniture because everyday we still
need to sit on a sofa
or else like jeremy or casey and
that deal with technology it moves super
fast
so so far doesn't change much in that
sense compared to a laptop or computer
so i wouldn't say
in a big picture it changes a lot
actually
yeah even though the exchanges like oh
people from home on their smart
furniture it's certainly take off
i wonder is it because home is something
that people want to run away from
technology maybe
and and and that suits me well like
furniture should be as low tech as
possible maybe
so i think there's not much change for
financial design in that way
karen do you actually agree with the
view in terms of your um career
experience
has things been um quite low to change
or have you experienced a lot of change
i know that you've gone through many
geographies and you have quite a
expensive career yeah what is your take
on on
this career yeah
well i would definitely say that there
is a lot of change and transformation
happening but i think um
jeremy said it as well that the core
design skills still very much apply so
for example one thing that we see with
the move towards circular design where
we need to see okay how can we design
both products and services that are
for example recyclable or reusable so
how can we use circular design
principles to coming back to the point
on furniture that are easily repairable
that are easily um
you can take apart um etc so it's in one
hand an expansion of your skills and an
expansion of your understanding so you
need to work with um with a whole set of
stakeholders including for example um
business designers business people
because you have to also think about the
business model that's involved but
fundamentally you need to tap on your
design skills if you understand that you
want to design something that is easily
repairable
then you need to know how you actually
go about doing that so it's about
holding on to your core design skills
and being flexible and continuously
learning to expand what it actually
means as a designer to work in this
space
thank you karen yeah so there were few
themes that were shared
during your presentations and one that
you've just mentioned is uh lifelong
learning i think this is one of the
common threads uh that all of you
speakers have shared that you evolved as
you went about your design career
um and i really liked what casey shared
uh or i think was jeremy i can't
remember but uh something very impactful
you know evolve with the times or become
awesome obsolete so um can you
share um in your design practice have
you guys embraced any shifts or pivots
and how have you then navigated and
embraced these changes in your careers
okay and i can start
and
then this is actually the experience in
my kind of design career
and i was actually when i was in dso
kind of like working in the human factor
specialist
and designing really hard way
right
and as i move
to creative and i start to learn about
software user interface
and when i join down and that gives me
the opportunity to marry these two
skills together and that gives
me really
you know the opportunity to you know
offer or design something more
meaningful a ritual experience to the
users
so i think that that is one of the uh
benefit of uh really expanding your
skill sets
and then we are also looking at new
technology 5g new ai and we have to deal
with all this new technology and how do
we harness all this new technology and
build into the products and to make it
really simple for users to use
so that that is something that we are
seeing now
in the uh kind of product design
situation yeah
thank you casey
um let me just add that i i think my my
fellow parents agree that design is part
art and part technology
and and it's part art i think we need to
be very passionate uh in life
and i think when you're passionate in
life you just get on with
understanding frustrating about what
life holds and trying to find solutions
and just leave everything be happiness
sadness and whatsoever so you just
consume you no matter what it's not a
job where you know like you think to you
need to upgrade yourself you need to
pivot yourself but i think it's a
constant thing for
if you are very committed designers or
you're really
a true blue designer it's always a new
to want to grow try to understand try to
find solutions
and i think with that it should come try
naturally if it's not then you probably
don't want to be a designer to start
with
yeah
thank you nathan so what casey shared
you know when he moved from hardware to
software to interfaces and what nathan
shared about merging the different art
and science together um really forms uh
the practice of design and uh and and i
think i think that's a common thread
that these um panelists have shared uh
about how they've navigated changes uh
as they went along their careers um i'm
wondering if if the rest have any other
things to add on before i move to the
next question
maybe just to jump in here as well i
think there maybe would be two big
changes from coming out of university
and then i'm actually experiencing what
design is uh in the real world
quote-unquote i think the first thing is
really the need to be um willing to
engage with the people you design for um
the thing that came up in a few of the
sharing that you need to facilitate you
need to actually be curious about the
people you design for talk to them
work with them in and get engaged with
them the users but all the production
which is something that might not
necessarily come natural to on all
designers and not necessarily something
that you get to that extent when you are
when you're studying design that you
really it is it's on one hand maybe an
art and craft that is very much you and
your craft but you also need to be
willing to go out so that's the first
thing um the second shift that has
happened for me in recent years really
this um moving and seeing a need to
understand more about business if you
work strategically in design and if you
want to advise and consult
a business on a product or a service you
also need to understand what it actually
means what um in introducing a new um
service a new business a new product
would actually mean to their business it
doesn't mean that you have to turn into
a business consultant but you need to
have an understanding of business models
and need to have an understanding of how
your product would actually come to
market and be a viable product there
thank you so much karen for the addition
of such a salient point that it's not
only about the users that we are
designing for but also the business
stakeholders that we have to engage
um and how do we uh look at these
stakeholders um as an entity uh and not
just in silos right
yep
okay great um and i think previously uh
along the thread of the the themes that
have come out in the conversations one
of it uh is you know with technology and
digital because nathan mentioned that
okay uh in furniture design um i would
rather keep uh very keep it very low
tech but with the others it seems that
technology and digital has been
disrupting
us in many ways have you seen that this
has actually disrupted the product
industrial design practice
sorry having said what i've said
try quite a bit no i think we still need
to engage technology to help selling for
example all development but not in
creativity in that sense
okay so embracing digital and technology
and enabling us to sell
um how has technology or digital um
disrupted
uh your practice anyone else
i mean fundamentally it's about the use
of the people that will use your design
so it can't be technology for the
technology's sake you need to understand
how they're going to use it so it's
about um employing it having it using it
as a means to an end but not as the not
just because it's the latest technology
um it has to be integrated we often hear
this all we need we need to include this
we need to include that we now need to
like design for the meta wars
it is really about
understanding what we're trying to
achieve and then finding the right um
application the right technology for
that and it might be low tech or it
might be high tech
yep
thank you karen so really using
technology as a tool as a means to an
end
and and how have you guys embraced this
and integrated this within your careers
that you just mentioned is that um
during the coffee times right
and
we kind of like
face the new norm where people kind of
work from home
and they couldn't go to office right and
they couldn't collaborate now the
technology really gives us the
opportunity to you know having everybody
to be in zoom
and what we're doing now doing this
regular webinar you know through zoom
and to have so many people uh to be in
this forum to hear and share you know
about knowledge so uh that is something
that the technology really has
destructed and also helped uh in times
like this uh in you know especially now
so we see that there will be a
continuous thing and there's still a lot
of opportunity there it is still a lot
of gaps that we are facing and finding
ways to address that
and
that actually presents a big opportunity
for designers to help solve and to help
people better collaborate and express
their thoughts you know
in
this kind of new hybrid work
situation
thank you casey it's already leveraging
technology to address the gaps um really
using it as opportunities to help make
our work meet hybrid uh much better
okay i'll move on to the next question i
just want to stress one thing although i
mean currently say that it's a tool for
design i just hope that the young
listener down here won't be like sitting
on a table and just design from sitting
there
i think design is always about engaging
people one-to-one real-life situation
and i'm just worried that young people
will just take it or just your home type
computers and google and do my research
rather than just talking to people
so at the end of the day design is
really about human to human interactions
and all that yeah
yeah
i agree with uh maintenance uh same and
true experience right
you really get a lot of
information
by talking to the users talking to the
customers and go around observing the
environment
and piecing all this data together and
that will allow you to kind of like
sharpen your intuitions and you know
your design abilities so and also
inspirations for you so i think that's
very important
thank you for the the great tip and
advice really get out there talk to
people
engage with your users
get curious about the people that you're
designing for they will inspire you and
your solutions
okay
and i see across you know speakers of
diversity of skill sets backgrounds that
they have shared you know from designing
products to designing systems
what would you say is the common thread
across this design disciplines that
could really benefit our users
uh our listeners
you know what something that they can
take be it coming from a non-design
background or if they come from a design
background what is it that really holds
the threat across all your disciplines
i mean there's definitely a lot of
connections but i think one thing that
that i find is really important for
design it's that it's not just about um
design as a problem solving tool which
it definitely is but you could argue
that engineering is that as well i think
what is really exciting about design is
also it's a problem defining tool a way
to actually frame problems and uncover
where the problems are
so i think this this curiosity back to
what i shared before like finding out
what's actually in the world and how we
can make it better whatever that might
be on a small scale to like a a
comfortable chair couch which can be
quite a blessing to like really um
improving a whole system
thank you karen
yeah i think design can be very
inspiring also i remember when i went to
the
factories in most of southeast asia
country like indonesia and malaysia that
produced my furniture i'm always greeted
by
by very friendly workers and they'll
smile i say oh this is a guy that did
that chair or this guy that did that
shelf
and surprisingly they appreciate beauty
even though in their daily life they're
just putting very cheap chairs and
tables for
for for for mass market in usa when you
do something beautiful they appreciate
it i don't understand why they
appreciate it but there must be
something that people appreciate beauty
and i think that's important as a
designer also or when we do design is
the beauty of design
yeah it's inspiring
thank you nathan
jeremy we have not heard from you would
you like to
share your thoughts on you know as uh
you know we've moved from designing just
products to to really
design systems
or along the whole various threads of
design disciplines that you've come from
what would you say holes
what are the similarities you see that
holds
the practice that you guys do together
yeah i think um
a lot have been said about you know
design and design as a career
and
interestingly after working for so many
years i
sometimes forgot that i'm a designer
and maybe because of the scope of my
work i i kind of
kind of slowly you know forgot about the
label i mean it's a label that was
created perhaps it can be changed in the
future
for something that is easier to
understand or you know maybe
tells us more about our profession
um
and i know that many people are
interested in design
um but this this tech is very heavy you
know to call someone a designer
um i don't have an answer for that but i
think um no one knows uh design unless
you step into it
unless you start doing it otherwise it's
it remains um
mysterious as a term
so i would encourage if anyone who's
interested in design um find out more
yourself talk to someone who has been
designed um
you can shadow them if they're willing
to allow you to shadow them
yeah for example
and
and that there's no um
there's no fixed definition of what a
designer can do i would say
there's no limit
um it's really up to your your personal
interests and talents
then you can define your own design
career
thank you so much uh jeremy i think you
have nicely summed up this question
uh you know across the design distance
it's not just the beauty and the craft
that you bring um to the table um and
and how you approach problem solving and
defining uh problem but also
your experience that makes you evolve
grow and and sharpen your your tool um
uh and and and use this in many ways
that you can will
um
to again circle back to actually problem
solving right for the for the people uh
for for users that you you
are designing for
so for the next 15 minutes i would like
to
um take a look at the poll and
uh
um
yeah pose the questions uh to the
speakers so
one of the questions uh is from someone
who is a non-designer coming from an
engineering background but extremely
interested in the design field
you know particularly in ux and product
design
you know what are some uh basic soft or
hard skills um you think this person
requires
uh
you know to apply for either internship
or just even start a career in this
field
what are some soft and hard skills to
get started
um
for an engineer i i myself is an
engineer and um i
do find
the skills that i have like the
analytical skills and engineering skills
and system engineering design skills
actually helps me a lot in my work
and uh
i think that that is a big plus
now um
in any addition to all these core skills
i think
some of the
design skills are very important uh
design principles
yeah and there's a lot of books and a
lot of results that you can go and learn
about it i think those skills are very
important skills in you know making a
product
uh really
something that the customers or users
would want to
and the other kind of skills is
basically the ability to work together
with people
your ability to work with different
functions different stakeholders
communication skills are those are
important skills and to exchange ideas
as well as to cut a line on uh you know
design directions
yeah so
that is my
advice yeah
thank you so much casey i just want to
add i think maybe to be a good listener
i think it's a very simple and expected
thing that we all thought we are but
really i think you really have to think
about whether are we a good listener and
i think being a designer is you have to
be one because you have to listen from
all stakeholders manufacturer clients
and all this thing and make the right
decision that kind of pleases everyone
most of the time
so i think to be a good listener it's a
very important skill set also
so good nathan thank you
maybe adding one more thing on the thing
is generally like being comfortable with
ambiguity because i think the design
process can be messy and i i think some
of the questions also pointed to just
like changes in
feedback change in scope etc is a very
common and normal thing so as a designer
being comfortable and confident to
navigate for that and without um
losing hope of getting frustrated and
keep your vision in mind i think it's
very important
and last but not least jeremy
i totally agree with what what karen
said because typically i i'm i'm the one
with the highest tolerance level
for ambiguity and chaos and sometimes
people couldn't stand that um the thing
is um it is important
um when we would like to
be a designer is to
also uh to to nurture some mindset for
example to understand that not the first
idea probably is not the best
and that we do time we do need time to
you know sit on the ideas for a while
just just like incubate
and as well as um
also called the open mind which is very
important
i've seen a lot of you know conflicts
between you know different professions
different experts and one of the key
issues
when one or both sides don't have the
open mind
to really think about you know the uh
from the other side or
take it as as an issue that can be
resolved together
yeah
thank you jeremy
sorry
it's very like logical innova analytical
and systematic and all that well designs
you need to be crazy and let go like
like what karine has saved people you
know ambiguity and all that so i think
maybe one of the tips i can tell these
guys you know go to a concert watch a
dance watch a play
sort see a painting on the sculpture i
think art really put us in a position
that we will question a lot of things
and i think you got to be very
comfortable about
the unknown so that you can start
thinking and lose a bit of control to
get more understanding about what's
around us and uh so i think it's
important if you are a very engineered
person you should let loose more maybe
like
gonna
start dancing i don't know
queer techniques getting comfortable
with the unknown uh reflecting really
what uh karen said about being
comfortable through ambiguity and
actually what jeremy said you know um
embracing change and he shared also and
being having grit you know in as a
mindset um and and and i think what
everybody exports here uh not just
communications that that casey mentioned
but listening as well um and and having
an open mind i think as a designer you
are the bridge and and you are actually
the middle person that brings um the
different opinions and perspectives
together
so i think that was really an enriching
um and and great tips that you've shared
with regards to this question um another
one is
now towards ui and ux you know how do
you think ui ux design has evolved now
we're not even talking about the
physical um product on industrial but
how does ui and ux design evolve what
has it involved here
um i mean the ui and ux
so
ui ux actually has
been actually getting more and more
challenging because
the technology has actually become way
advanced and there's so many
use cases that we need to look after
and to distill all this complexity to a
simple solution i think that that is the
uh the challenge here
and we have to
kind of learn about all the new
technology the sensors the ai
theory and then to understand how it
works and then to blend into the
solutions that uh you know something
that users can use
so i that that is actually something
that we have been kind of experiencing
for the past
uh kind of like recent years
right and dealing with all this
complexity and how to translate it to a
simple solution
i think that is how the ui ux has
actually evolved
and
to deal with this i think that also
means that we have to
learn more skills and understand uh you
know learn more detect new technologies
that's out there
and then uh and then find ways to blend
into the design solutions
for users
thank you so much casey
really creating simplicity out of
complexity through the interactions that
users have either
with your products or your service
okay um then the next question uh would
be you know
uh to the panelists what do you think
are the most important aspects when
looking for an education in product
design and does it matter that an
institution is reputable i think some of
you guys are educators here
maybe at nathan or jeremy you can take a
step at that
i thought victoria said i shouldn't see
anything because i'm in the school
i shouldn't need them
and jeremy go ahead
well
i think i think as i grew up i realized
that the school is
very important but it's not about who
you learn but the people you know
so you have good connection after you
graduate and you can get more
business or tips after you you graduate
so the friends are important so i don't
think the school is that important
actually
yeah
yeah i think a lot of things boils down
to ourselves
i think you got a driven individual and
you're resourceful and your street smart
then you should be okay anyway
and i think a designer should have that
kind of
kind of of attitude actually even when
you're a very young person like 16 or 18
years old you should always be very
resourceful and very street smart uh
having said that i think
i think the use of today is a bit
more um
more risk adverse
so they would like to hear podcasts like
this to guide them through
but when i was young a lot of us are
just like trying things out and find our
own solution and i think that's why it
also makes
in my in the end makes us a better
designer also i don't know because we
fail a lot we try a lot
against the ambiguity help us to
to navigate to make mistakes
so uh what am i talking about so what
i'm saying is that um
if if you're good and you are
resourceful and you you know are tough
you have the grit then i think wherever
you go it's fine if you are not then i
think maybe picked up a famous one
whatsoever
i think thank you nathan um really for
that response so it's not really about
the name of the school it's the
connections that you make it's about
being responsible and again i think the
theme of grid comes out you know really
finding the answers to the challenges
that we face um this is a day to day job
of all the designers that are here right
okay
so um very yeah go ahead perhaps i can
add on uh frankly speaking when i was a
student i i didn't think about a
reputation i didn't know which school
was school
after graduate i realized oh i didn't
think perhaps i should have but then
again
how does it matter in the career i mean
after all the school education only take
up
just a small percentage of your sort of
career which is really at the beginning
preparing you and i believe a lot of
people teach more or less the same thing
yeah but of course you want to have a
school that has some reputation because
you also believe that the students there
are more serious or more passionate etc
etc so it's really down to the students
um
yeah i mean with good students good
designs come from all over the place
from different schools
thank you so much jeremy and to that you
have a question directed at you um
regarding to your presentation earlier
is it essential to have a right and left
brain to be successful in industrial
design and also experience in business
to really understand business and design
strategy
well i
well everyone has a right and left brain
i believe
it's just how much you use either side
right on both sides
um
and i do believe that it's it it also
needs to match what you're pursuing
some some jobs some positions or roles
need to be more you know logical and
rational
and your your teammates rely on your
capabilities in that so you can imagine
if the whole team is made of imaginative
you know uh dreamy uh designers what's
gonna happen to the you know to the
outcome
so we need a good balance um i always
admire people with strong engineering
mind
whether you're engineer or designer i
like that because it can you know
complement
something i perhaps is a little bit weak
in
probably a
more on the right side but we need both
yeah so there's nothing wrong if you are
stronger in you know either side
i think to add to that i don't think you
need
them but i think it's good that if you
aware the existence of them
and think that's all you need to know
yeah
yeah and it's definitely good to work in
and it's happening in many design teams
that you have a diverse team of
different backgrounds with different
thinking styles because that is really
what will come where you will get the
great ideas if you have people who think
differently from you um they challenge
your ideas and push them forward i think
that is really where
it doesn't have to be just only your
brain you can lean on other brains as
well
great thank you karen yeah so
maybe
uh what i what we found really uh
kind of beneficial
uh to kind of like uh our work
environments and uh to have
people
from different backgrounds together
and then bouncing ideas
and then very often uh we were able to
generate an idea that is better than the
original ones
so i think the
the part where everybody working
together and you know
collaboratively and that is one of the
uh very important factor
thank you so much casey for summing that
up so beautifully it's really about
diverse teams working in
multi-disciplinary teams where different
um skill sets come together you could be
you know strong in your right way right
brain and and your colleague could be
one that brings in the analytical parts
but you guys work together to actually
produce a beautiful outcome i think this
is what um uh working as a team and the
speakers have shared that you are not a
lone ranger
as a designer you know you work together
with a diverse team
um and as a designer uh to a next
question by jeremy how do you decide
what compromises can be made on your
design version when limited by
manufacturing or by budget
you know so we work with constraints
how do we decide what compromises can be
made
that's the holy grail in fact
and i don't think it's it's a designer's
sole decision it has to be
a joint decision yeah
um whether it's as a compromise or
whether it's um
maybe it's a little bit too pessimistic
but uh
we do need some trade-offs sometimes and
we need balance yeah perhaps balance is
a better term because
uh like i always in tom i think there's
no better solution only better solution
you probably can't achieve the best in
the world because
if you manage to achieve it probably
already you know
miss the deadline
yeah so achieving a good balance is good
enough
okay so i hope uh that answer is is um
the question is being answered that it's
all about balance it's um not just
coming to a decision yourself but having
an approach together with your
stakeholders um
yeah to see what what are the kind of
compromises that can be made in order to
make that decision not it doesn't have
to be the best but at least a better one
um
yes okay and we deal with a lot of this
kind of trade-off
and you heard of very often
and then
what we found i think one of the skill
sets that is pretty important is
the skill sets of prioritizations
and there's a way to prioritize
you know certain uh features and
functions
and then um you know having the ability
to do that trade-off uh you know
analysis you know i think is something
that is useful that will be useful
for that kind of situation
okay
yeah that's great um casey i think
really prioritizing um so that you can
make the right decisions for trade-offs
sorry karen please go ahead
no i think it's me oh newton yeah well i
think furniture is less of that
constraint because um
you know when you when you do a digital
product there's a lot of costs in
involved like billions or millions of
dollars for to develop a product where
furniture are lesser so they are more
chance to to try an error and they are
more creative freedom by designer
so anyone out there who just want to
work with yourself i think instead of
being a furniture designer than a
teacher
i think the only thing is only the cost
maybe um because of the complexity of
producing something uh in terms of
furniture design
yeah
okay so we see two different aspects um
one with constraints others with just
the cost of manufacturing um but again
you know we do have to weigh um
yeah the constraints that we have in
order to
make a good decision
so um to the panelist
a question from nasha in regards to
okay to what jeremy said about making
things happen when it's not happening
what is your go-to method when being met
with friction in your team so this is
all um to all pendulums but referring to
i think jeremy's presentation
what would be a go-to method when met
with friction
somehow what i shared invited a lot of
questions
[Laughter]
okay so so i asked for it um yeah
uh
i mean to the true spirit of you know
design design thinking the first thing
we need to do is to understand what is
the friction and what's the cause of it
because if you don't know that it's very
hard for us to deal with it right and
there are many ways to deal with the
frictions
um
yeah so a simple answer is we need to
understand what it what is causing the
friction
okay so really understanding the root
cause
yeah
is there this person perfectly mentioned
is there any go-to method so jeremy you
did say uh design thinking and you did
mentioned uh go to the root course and
yeah
speakers um
if i must use the so-called jargon which
is empathy
again you know empathy is not just for
users empathy it's also for our
colleagues for clients
for for the people who are involved
yeah so that applies
no sorry sorry casey yeah maybe maybe i
can add that um when there's friction
arises
many times
you just don't have that data enough to
make that decisions
so if that's friction that shows that
there's some more things that needs to
be done
to collect that data in and then so that
the team can make a more informed
decisions or design
a solution
and that is
something that we learned
you know during our work
so gathering enough data to make an
informed division thanks casey nathan
you wanted to share something
yeah
but this sounds very petty um
i think frictions apply to everything we
do as long as human to human direction
so
i think it boils down to
does it happens to the particular
project you're handling or there's a
long line of issues that's been built up
between you and the person whatsoever
so i think that has to be clear first
and i think as creative person we're
always very passionate about our own
belief
and like what casey has said or jeremy
has said do we need a lot of empathy
again a good listener to know where the
other party comes from so i think it's
always good communication
and as a designer we always need to be
very good at communicating because we
need to design from understanding all
other issues also anyway
so um
in a singapore context just buy a copy
and and that's all and i don't know
myself right petty not very professional
i don't know but in financial life we
just very passionate i always argue the
technicians or the engineer they'll want
the wood to be super thick or super fat
or so and i wanted the dinners are
possible and we argue any of that we
just go for lunch and that's it but
again it's applied to all kind of
of communication while you're in the
workplace anyway so
uh i think it's empathy you just have to
see where the guy's coming from you know
that that's all yeah
yeah i really a common thread um empathy
or just have lunch
yeah just as
and and don't talk about it and have a
good life i'm sure the team here karen
jeremy casey we are all like that we
argue passionately about a project and
they'll say okay let's go for lunch and
go for a drink that's all
and we always have to do that we need to
drink a lot after
every project everything
what a nice conclusion
and it's almost towards drinking time
uh happy hour so i will take the last
question because we've come to
almost come to the end um one last
question is regards to uh from jenny any
acne notes on how candidates for design
opening impressed you during a job
interview
so basically what can you what can the
person do to stand up
i just start with for me i'm looking for
the right attitude
the right attitude in wanted to learn
and the right due to able to suffer
and uh
the attitude to want to
doing a good job
yeah so for me it boys sound to really
having a good attitude
in um
whatever that that comes along uh yeah
for them
i would second that i think attitude
definitely skills are important
absolutely but i think attitude is one
of the key things and i'm always very
interested in people who have a very
diverse background and that can mean
like um different places that they have
lived in or different um educational
backgrounds so designer or from
psychology or architect who went to ui
et cetera so i think those are
interesting things and getting
understanding what motivated them to go
for these different experiences and
different changes that that's what's
always interesting
thank you karen
casey or jeremy any any notes of where
uh
an interview has impressed you and meet
you i would say
um someone who are really passionate in
what they are doing
and
someone
who
has really strong interest in solving a
user's problem you know
relating to the user's problem and then
someone who has the persistency to
continue to you know solve a problem
and not to give up easily yeah
yeah
perhaps i can add a little bit um
something i find quite personal i'm
looking for someone as well besides
those traits someone who is um
reflective
which means um by looking at their own
work they're able to reflect and know
what's what was not done well and what
could have been done you know better
than next time
um the thing is you're dealing with
experienced designers and the
interviewers um they know what are the
issues in your project so you can't
easily talk your way through you know
trying to you know glorify the work
but the best strategy is to be honest
and then say that you know what was not
done well and that's that can win you
know the heart of your interviewers
okay thank you jeremy so um really to
sum up our audience here it's really the
passion and the attitude that you bring
to the table
um your curiosity that really drives
your the diversity of your background
having the grit and being reflective
about your practice that helps you
mature in your um in your design career
and i think that was really an enriching
conversation with the four panelists
here so i thank you so much for the
response and i'm apologize that i'm not
able to go through all the many
questions um but i would like to end
with one uh statement that a um
audience has shared and he's asked
directly to mr nathan young can i shadow
you i'm a fan of the design i've
collected four solo chairs from a
previous company air division
so anyhow my last statement is you may
contact them after this session and i'll
hand the time over to juliana thank you
back to you
all right thank you so much once again
victoria and the recipients for sharing
your very real life experience and very
candid answers with our audience to our
audience we would appreciate it if you
could help us to complete a short survey
for this webinar to help us to improve
on our future programs there will be a
special giveaway where you can win one
of the three fifty dollar middle ground
and tanuki raw vouchers at the national
design center plus an exclusive hard
copy of the pda 2020 publication when
you share your greatest takeaway from
the webinar and there's i'm very sure
there were many so please do scan the qr
code for the survey form and if you
would like to find out more about the
various upcoming programs the national
design center has lined up do also scan
the qr code that you see on your screens
and with that we will be ending the
session for today thank you once again
to all of our speakers and to all of you
for spending your thursday afternoon
with us we look forward to seeing you at
our future events have a good evening
ahead and goodbye
do
[Music]
bye